the sweet aroma of a flower a pleasure
made possible by our sense of smell
which is also one of our least used
senses that's why scientists were late
to catch on that an estimated 80% of
people who present no obvious symptoms
of coronavirus in fact as partial or
total anosmia many of them have
experienced just a Norseman which is
olfaction loss of all function of the
effective capacity no other symptom no
cough no fever just a fever can be
easily detected with a thermometer or
thermographic camera but not the loss of
smell which is highly subjective now the
school of engineering and center of
aroma and taste at Chile's Catholic
University have developed an objective
test to measure it the kit consists of
six extremely familiar aromas a person
is asked to identify three you can fail
the test and not be infected but you
can't pass if you are says professor I
will see and then you can isolate the
person that shows some of the some
affective dysfunction and corroborate if
this person has or hasn't the Kovach 19
we want to try it out so I've always
prided myself on having a good sense of
smell but now we're going to see no
matter those all correct so I passed the
test and thank God and the amazing thing
about this is that it's not only very
very quick it's extremely inexpensive
about 30 cents per test which means that
it's a very viable alternative in
countries that can't afford widespread
testing with the with the classic kovat
19 examinations a pilot program is
starting this week but already there's
widespread interest in using the kit in
areas where there is a high probability
of infections in industries that can't
stop for example like food production in
mines or hospitals they can test them
frequently and if they don't pass seen
them to take the traditional test to
confirm
indeed just like having a high
temperature does not mean that you have
kovat 19 losing your sense of smell
isn't proof of infection but the smell
test does provide a new early warning
system to help detect those who are
spreading the disease without even
knowing it
Lucia Neumann al Jazeera Santiago